[Music]
my friend
virgin in parenthesis my friend Virgin
by the way gets very possessive and
needy with rave girls o oh immediately
this is
weird so I have this friend good guy
unfortunately he has not gotten laid
ever virgin
[Laughter]
another parenthesis this guy does not
[__] yeah
yeah at the Rave there was two scenarios
one girl comes up to me sorry you know
this dude is Young because at the Rave
the Rave it's the one of three he's been
to yeah girl comes up to me and flirts
with me I tell her I am 10 years old
when asked and she says I I guess I
won't be able to you now my friend
interjects and changes his tone to his
customer service voice and says well you
can still me oh and got all flustered
ruining the vibe I had with this chick
and she left shortly after she was into
me and was complimenting me Etc no biggy
well pause dude pause customer service
voice what does that mean well you can
still [__] me yeah yeah yeah well you
could still [__] me yeah well you could
still [__] me there's so many ways I
could I would be happy to help you with
that you can still [__] me
oh my gosh that be to your satisfaction
today and please after we' done this
interaction you'll get a call with a
survey
surve so please fill out that and rate
my flirting well that's not a problem
because you could still [__] me today
and uh it's entirely up to you yeah well
that's awesome because you could still
[__] me today I like the fact that the
the guy writing this post clearly
thought that was a sick [__] line
yeah she asked me how old I was I said
10 yeah [__] [__] rocked her world
dude [__] absolutely slammed she laughed
like for 10 minutes you know what that
is and then and then sucked me like an
oyster what I was talking with my
producer Alex about this and we were
talking about a funny phenomena where
like a hot guy turns into the dude that
scares the hose okay like he's hot for
some years and starts doing drugs then
he like turns like scary yeah yeah okay
like that's the beginnings of that yeah
yeah yeah I told her I'm
10 yeah [__] works every time [__] works
every time how old are you by the way 10
just say 10 it's awesome [__] works yeah
I told her I'm seven I called her a
pedophile yeah she loved that yeah I'm a
little baby I'm wearing Spider-Man
Underpants yeah I got my a little Hulk
underwear on yeah how old are you 3
months just was born born yesterday dick
is big as my body yeah bit of a
conundrum isn't it baby
dick
ah how old are you eight months I have a
little baby dick too dude [__] worked
every
time I tell her I'm 10 you know I hate I
hate this dude because if we said that
someone would believe
us how old are you 10 oh where's your
mom
oh you don't have like a stamp or
anything what happened where's your
bracelet yeah you're running around this
your she grabs our hand we should find
your mom right your mom yeah yeah he his
mom is missing yeah yeah I'm
10 oh my god oh okay we'll do an
announcement over the speaker oh [__]
the
DJ yo this dude's 10 has anyone seen his
mom what's this next bit what's your
mom's name little man I'm 10 I'm 10 we
know you're 10 who's your mom this is
[__] brutal all right read the second
scenario we meet two girls at the smoker
section he starts talking to one and I
talk to the other the one he was talking
to kept complimenting me Etc this guy
man suck this guy sucks this guy sucks
he's he's definitely the worst friend
ever yeah the one he's talking to kept
complimenting me
Etc I like also like ET yeah yeah you
know she like compliment me saying she
wants to suck my dick dick she like
spitting on it etc etc but clearly she
was all moled
up e Mano moled up I'm telling you man
this guy's scary but clearly she was all
moled up so I didn't think much of it
nor really let it change my frame oh
what however whilst whilst we were whil
what the [__] whilst we were all into
like Renaissance author there Jesus he
kept trying to dance behind her which is
fine and all since they were kissing
Etc we got to meet this idiot but he was
all over her when she was trying to
dance L and when she'd move to my side
so she can dance he'd magically appear
behind her
Etc at one point she moved away from him
and started dancing in front of me
shaking her hips
etc etc again but I didn't follow
through on the in initiation I kid you
not exam this is capitals I kid you not
I saw his head pop out in a crouched
State on my left literally analyzing the
gap between me and her it was 15 to it
was 10 to 15 in it was a 10 to 15 inch
Gap why is that relevant yeah he stayed
there analyzing the Gap physically for
like 15 seconds LOL then jumped in from
the side and swapped places with me I've
had my fair share of sexual experiences
Etc so I'm not so determined to get laid
or be so possessive over rave girls Etc
not that there is anything wrong with
rave girls but generally speaking if you
get with a rave girl or make out/ dance
the odds are that the next day they'll
wake up in a sour mood from the cown and
more often than not regret their choices
and not really stick around
Etc I just wanted to share maybe I'm in
the wrong somehow and I'm coming off as
a dick but I but him being possessive
and overbearing with girls especially
during a rave is something I want to
teach him about oh dude this guy stinks
sick post Rave sub go back to the Rave
subreddit oh yes let's [__] go I just
started getting into Raves and haven't
really been to that many so maybe this
is a total non-issue I don't know I saw
dudes with small or like normal size
snakes go bottomless I want to go
bottomless but I have a huge Dawn
oh oh I get the feeling that I shouldn't
or I could and just get ready for people
to be to Mean Mug me oh yeah I just
think I would feel so [__] amazing to
have nothing covering my body while I
lose my mind to some super loud music
there so there's so many layers here
that is killing me first of all I don't
I think I'm going to ask Reddit today if
I should go bottomless yeah with my huge
[__] it's like literally the you could
not have a better problem than that
yeah like if that's the problem yeah
that's keeping you up at night I don't
know whether or not to go bottomless at
a rave cuz my dick is too big how many
how many Raves do you say you've been to
how many Raves yeah um how many R aves
have you been to a handful I would say
one of my old co-workers was telling me
a story about like it was like the last
Rave he had been to and he said it was a
circumstance where I I think he he said
a friend was a DJ day and gave him
tickets he's just kind of there to
support and he's it was a very like
begrudging thing and he distinctly
remembered walking past these two like
young people on Molly just like you know
their jaw going crazy and he was saying
he felt old cuz in that moment he goes
dude where are your [__] parents
mentally he thought that where are your
[__] parents yeah he's like I got to
get out of
here